[Music]
no
no no
i invented dry scooping apparently now
it's become a tech talk trend can you
believe this to dry scoop protein powder
i made concerns it could lead to choking
pneumonia or heart disturbances wait no
no no they even got it wrong idiots it's
a pre-workout pre-workout isn't protein
powder why would you what would you uh
new study i like uh they're doing
studies on this finds dry scooping
videos had over 8.2 million likes a
bright you just look up this one has 24
million likes
it could lead to over consumption oh no
listen it's awful it's the dumbest [ __ ]
ever
it leads to overconsumption what does
that what the [ __ ] does that mean yeah
death sure all right so tick tock's
latest trend i think this has gone on
for a while actually but now uh tick
tock is trying to shut it down threw up
once like breathing in my mom
so take a breath
first
open your mouth back and forth with your
teeth there you go put some water in
don't breathe
give it a swish
[ __ ]
you gotta do it like that
you gotta do that first
all right don't don't they understand it
could lead to over consumption
i dry scooped my pre-workout once so
naturally this time i got a little too
cocky and try to get fancy with it by
pouring it down my throat instead of my
mouth oh that's a terrible idea you dumb
[ __ ] i had a heart attack oh hell yeah
how did that happen so i i only tried to
pre-workout a couple of times and as
someone that you know drinks a lot of
caffeine i didn't expect much would
happen at all but i read the package i'm
like okay so i need to wait like a
couple of minutes before the workout so
i sat down for my computer after i drank
it and all of a sudden my my body's just
starting to tingle and my face is just
completely numb and i'm like
oh cool so i'm dying pre-workout is it's
really [ __ ] strong it's out of all
things to like eat consume without even
uh drinking water it just seems like a
terrible [ __ ] idea and it's so
typical tick-tock to start a trend out
of this right all right guys so i had a
heart attack as most of you guys know
from taking this redcon one total war
and i dry scooped it but i think even if
i put it in water i would have been
asked out anyways um
hmm that's a good point actually taking
a drive pre-workout scoop because i saw
it training on tick tock right ended up
in hospital because i had a heart attack
bro yeah pre-scripting is bad enough but
if you're not aware how strong
pre-workouts can be and you don't even
work out and you don't even i don't know
you're a young frail
smaller individual i don't know what
this call it yeah it's gonna [ __ ] you up
i i assume it's the kind of thing you
build up some immunity for after you use
some of it it's just uh
yeah i can't really blame people for not
knowing but then you add dry scooping to
the formula and it's like no you just
[ __ ] dumb now my symptoms were heavy
chest and chest pains but i ignored it
and i continued doing my workout because
i'm not a beta and then i had nausea and
fatigue and then i went home and i took
a shower and then when i went to work i
was in the locker room because y'all
know i'm a i'm
and um i got chest pains again and it
went to my back and then my left side
started hurting in my left side
and that's when i knew it was a heart
attack and not anxiety
that's my story time that's it i don't
know what else to say i can't read the
text yo is that a protein shake in the
back let's go
guys
pewdiepie shakers
what you do is you go you grab the scoop
and you put it in
with water or anything really check them
out link in description
it's great it's called dry scooping and
it may have given one woman a heart
attack experts say is not one to play
around with take a look who the are the
experts i'm sorry there's always expert
who the who are they where are they are
they experts the one that
find the amount of likes on the video
these so-called pre-workout powder
protein mixes aren't regulated by the
fda
doctors say a single scoop can have
three or four times as much caffeine as
a cup of coffee
normally you'd never get that much in
just one sitting but with dry scooping
it's going straight into your
bloodstream hell yeah all right i kind
of want to try it right i'm kidding
don't do it why would he go straight
into your bloodstream just because
shouldn't it go equally as fast if you
water it down at least a little bit
right that can cause way more than just
your typical caffeine jitters it can
jack up your blood pressure or even
cause a heart attack
doctors say it's best to follow the
directions on the packaging and mix it
with water or milk so it doesn't make
you sick i mix mine with my saliva i
will see those videos pop up what
happens when you pre-workout yeah a
tick-tocker chugged eight scoops of
pre-workout supplement this is what
happened to his brain it's all of course
his ticket chugged eight scoops of
pre-workout supplement
this is what happened to his
nothing it was already melted he's a
tick-tocker is a 25-year-old man
presenting to the emergency room
unconscious this is in april how is this
still going on karen tells the admitting
nurse that she found her son
unresponsive on the floor you see j.a
was a fitness tic talker who was just
trying to make it i know it's not funny
but why would you take eight scoops of
pre-workout my dude why why would you do
that why my kids i need gains damn it
eating in his neck as his eyes started
bulging out of his head she found her
son huddled over on the floor as she
calls for 9-1-1 and he's brought to the
emergency room ah come on
it would have been fine
right and notice that along with his
high blood pressure his heart was
beating erratically all of these
together could mean that this is a
problem with just his heart but
something's wrong when doctors looked at
his pupils they noticed that one was
bigger than the other and the heart
doesn't control the eyes the brain does
and if the brain controls the heart too
then could the brain be the cause of his
problems
doctors send ja to get a scan of his
head the images suggest that parts of
his brain have been bleeding because the
brain's enclosed inside a hard space the
skull bleeding into the brain would mean
that the brain's expanding the bleed
isn't going to big brain you get big
brain from scooping just for the record
in case someone wants to be a dumbass
i'm literally taking up tiny portions of
my finger right it's a bit different
keep pushing the brain up against the
sides of the skull until the blood
vessels start to crush themselves as the
brain falls jesus christ
a single scoop has 200 milligrams of
caffeine which is around 2 cups of
coffee the recommended daily maximum for
caffeine is 400 milligrams if j.a
swallowed eight scoops of pre-workout in
just a few seconds it means that the
caffeine content that he took was equal
to chugging seventeen cups of coffee
four times the recommended daily limit
caffeine is a stimulant and increases
adrenaline in the blood so it increases
heart rate it could explain why ja felt
jittery it increases blood pressure
which if high enough can stress the
blood vessels to the point of rupturing
the walls of those blood vessels oh my
god
but is caffeine alone enough to cause a
blood pressure so high that the machine
can't even read it haha pre-workout go
glug glug so people try to warn against
uh dry scooping on tech talk
saying you know maybe it's not a good
idea
there's actually nothing funny or cool
about it it's just really dumb it didn't
stop anyone tick-tock just has to keep
going you can't suck it's dry stopping
now as you just heard right there that
that young bruh look at these what are
you doing woman who's only 20 said that
she had a heart attack yeah this is very
happy scooping queens
let's go queens let's go queen scoop
scoop
it's like cinnamon challenge but with
extra heart problems
yeah bruh
said that she had a heart attack yeah
this is very alarming and dangerous and
cardiologists say this new fitness trend
could put someone who tries it in the
hospital or really even worse channel 3
eyewitness news reporter aaron edwards
explains why don't think too much there
you go but why why would you do that
stop it pre-workout powder and ingest
let's go 3m crew war how i feel every
end
every am i am i feel it i feel so good
or you could just you know like work out
i know i'm supposed to sell g fuel now
but you don't need to drink anything
before i work out it's it's possible
you just start lifting [ __ ] i don't know
it's crazy right
i heard of it but i have an 11 year old
so i said have you seen this and she's
like oh mom yeah i have owner of energy
zone fitness julie kranek was shocked to
find her daughter knew of the dry scoop
trend
after a search she found dozens of
videos bruh how can you let your kids be
on tick tock i know there's like an age
limit of 13 year olds to be on tick tock
right and it's the same with youtube but
the problem is like no one gives a [ __ ]
i saw an article
saying a a girl swallowed magnets
because she saw a tick-tock trend about
something magnet related girl 6 needs
live chain saving surgery after swirling
23 magnets copying a tick-tock trend
like i guess at the end of the day it
comes down to the parents are right but
man what it do this trend isn't only
dangerous because it's a choking hazard
but it's a caffeine content that could
be harmful to ingest at one time
it's so cringy too like seeing all these
people that i don't know
it feels cringy to even say but they
pack no muscles like why do they care
about doing pre-work yet four times the
amount of a cup of coffee and when you
ingest caffeine so quickly and that such
a large amount can cause very dangerous
sudden rises in heart rate blood
pressure um this increases our risk for
irregular
it also increases the risk for over
overconsumption
bro just say you're gonna die if you do
it that's the only way that would stop
me if i was uh 12. bro you're gonna die
if you do that oh my bad guess i'll stop
don't say it's dangerous that just makes
them want to do it more you idiots
promise twelve some of that you
shouldn't do that's dangerous i'm like
oh really
yes i'm a sociopath come on and fitness
trainers and doctors say using that bro
there's so many people doing it it's so
crazy
that's correct you work out or lose
weight any faster
fail
fail fail cool i hate tick tock again
now thanks for watching subscribe for
more
bye bye i have new merch represent.com
super happy about this so i think you
guys will like it check it out